I'm curious because I recently in the
past like year or two got like super
addicted and super into twitch how did
you like you get into it because I as
far as I've ever been on Twitch and
watched it you've always been streaming
on it so I started on Justin TV in 2010.
did you did you so did you have that
thing where it automatically transferred
you no because I took I took a six year
break I streamed in 2010 and I stopped
at the end of 2010 okay and then I
picked it up again in 2016 but I was on
YouTube and then I switched to Twitch in
2018. right Justin TV slapped though
were you guys ever on Justin TV
it was great Justin TV had like 24-hour
reruns of like Angry Video Game Nerd
four player podcast oh yeah it was so
wild back then you it didn't have a rule
you weren't allowed to stream non-gaming
stuff as well no Justin TV was anything
goes twitch started as only gaming yeah
and they changed after a while yeah then
they eventually added the IRL category
yeah that's right yeah because Justin TV
was the original streaming yeah because
there were so many people streaming
games they were like let's make a
separate uh separate website just for
that just for that everyone else streams
on Justin.tv they didn't really all get
moved over and then eventually got moved
over because uh Justin.tv got shut down
they got bought out yeah oh yeah they
did they did Joe is that your Tamagotchi
oh my God
sorry okay give him your belt Joey give
him the belt he's asleep now
he was just like I need to go to bed
it's fine I'm curious what do you think
of all the uh the twitch stuff they
recently did oh yeah oh there's the
splits and everything splits and a few
other things they did I mean obviously
they changed kind of changed the rules
on gambling uh you see it's a little
better it's a step in the right
direction I think it's definitely a step
um but yeah I mean what do you think
where twitch is going it shows a very
clear lack of like understanding the
platform and the streamers yeah like
this was a point Ludwig brought up in
one that I think is super true twitch is
super bloated they have so many
Engineers but I can't name anything
they've put out that is good in the last
five years like elevated chats or dog
[ __ ] I think we can all agree [ __ ]
it's terrible like they don't understand
they don't do anything
Super Chat yeah but it goes under the
stream most of the time so you can't see
it as a streamer what yeah the elevated
Jet doesn't elevate it goes under your
stream and you never see it it's a
complete scam I think I think they want
to get people to not donate yeah I think
they're trying to stop people from
getting donations because twitch doesn't
get a cut of it because it's like why
would we do that when we can't take 50
right yeah yeah I I yeah like you said
it seems bloated and also it it's odd I
remember seeing a few articles that
obviously they replaced a lot of the
staff and slowly it became you know less
uh focused on like the community and
more about the business side of it which
obviously as good in some senses but
others it's like all right this is a
clear message of what they're looking
for but they just don't know how to do
it right like because you would think
the last thing you'd want to Target is
the streamers because I looked it up
recently 76 of all twitch traffic comes
from the top one percent of streamers
yeah yeah which and I think expanding
further it was like 99 of all twitch
traffic comes from the point one percent
of top streamers yeah which most of the
top streamers are on the 73rd yep almost
all of them like pretty much everyone on
that leak is in the 70 30 split so
targeting them pushes them to maybe go
to YouTube where it is 70 30. yeah and
they usually get a bag for the switch
Yeah like twitch should be that's like
the last resort taking from the
streamers they should go for like we
have a million Engineers maybe we start
making some Cuts here instead they're
not doing anything it's odd I I don't
really know what that objective or goal
with it is yeah I guess we'll see I
don't know it just has to be like short
term
or something it's like what are they
gonna do next I guess which is kind of
the worrying have you thought about
going back to streaming on YouTube or
you're going to stay on Twitch for a
while I still think twitch is the better
platform at the moment I think it's
definitely the better live streaming
experience as a viewer absolutely
definitely but if they keep shoving so
many odds in their face like it's it's
going to get beaten by YouTube YouTube
you skip the ads right like it's better
yeah as a streamer they keep trying to
and it's just because then like when you
play a three minute ad it's a lot like
it's so much and it and it interrupts
the content it's not an ad break it's
like I'm still streaming I'm still doing
stuff and now I'm just annoying people
because they can't see it whereas if it
was an ad break no one would see
anything and everyone everyone is
understanding of the fact that nothing
is happening right so that's why the ads
are playing yeah and so I think that's
why it's frustrating uh yeah I remember
I had the automatic ads on oh that's
yeah because I had a I had a I had a do
you know this twitch has this automatic
ads thing yeah yeah so I had um someone
from twitch this is a very very long
time ago they reached out to me and
they're like hey
um if you run these automatic ads it's
really good your viewers really enjoy it
because there's no more pre-rolls that's
the way they sold it to me and I was
like oh that makes sense yeah that's
good because if every every one minute
of ads
um for 10 minutes on your channel when
people click on it for the first time
there won't be a net right so if there's
an ad every 10 minutes for one minute
there'll be no pre-rolls but that that's
a lot of that
I turned it on and I very suddenly found
out that people hated it they were like
it's very backwards logic yeah because
what you forget is that yeah okay maybe
it's good at getting the initial
retention yeah when you actually go and
look at your stats people are normally
watching streams on average if you do
like a six hour stream people are
normally watching for two hours right
like it's a long time yeah and that's a
lot of ads to throw that way especially
if they're already giving you five bucks
a month you know like five bucks a month
for like maybe like the occasional bits
and you know donations and stuff as well
if they're really dedicated it's like
I'm not Netflix you don't get a catalog
I barely turn up half the time five
bucks a month for that like and then I
have to make you sit through it at every
minute yeah like what like at least
Netflix you get like Rick and Morty
maybe a Terminator movie
you get you know what I mean it's like
you're asking a lot so I it's
frustrating that they they kind of push
you towards this in my opinion sorry I
asked this question I just used as a
vehicle to Brent no I think it's a good
rant to have the ads are outrageous
they're putting way too much focus on
like incentivizing streamers to run ads
Yeah by taking that split away they keep
hyping up their ad incentive program to
make up for it right which is super is
coming and the ad incentive program
doesn't really make sense after you're a
certain size because the amount of money
they're going to give you for the amount
of intrusion you'd have to do is not it
doesn't make it it has a lot of really
really small streamers I think give them
an extra little paycheck but I just
don't think it like I've never looked at
it until once that it made sense yeah
it's the Netflix category even still
good uh just what do you mean I don't
know Netflix category yeah yeah I'm
sorry yeah you were talking about
Netflix sorry
tangent you know Netflix even still have
a good catalog sorry that's what I meant
to say the thing is is if you don't live
in the US yes like if you if you're
outside of the US there's pretty much no
competition think about it okay
in the UK there's not really much do you
have HBO Max you can't HR Max outside no
yeah we can't get Hulu
in Japan though but the catalog is [ __ ]
and and the the one thing that does suck
is that a lot of the time because of the
way that Japan does things like anime
will be on Netflix Japan but because of
the deal there won't be English
subtitles so it's really frustrating
because if I swap to like if I was in
America it would have English subtitles
but they just take it off just for Japan
because of some licensing
shows is fine some shows I really need
the subtitles yeah it's just it's weird
but yeah I think I don't know I used to
watch a lot of Netflix I barely watch
Netflix anymore and I realized this the
other day actually I'm like [ __ ] I'm
playing I'm paying for a subscription
basically just for anime and the anime
catalog is like even like deteriorating
yeah well I I watched uh on the on the
plane ride over here they made a
documentary about oh yeah you watch
documentaries
I'm a fan of documentary even if they're
dog [ __ ] like I just love seeing what
people think is good enough for a
documentary and seeing how they present
the story but lately there's been this
weird Trend and I don't know if there's
a few production companies that are
pumping these out where it was about the
GameStop stock oh nice it was a
documentary on that literally just came
out wow and um it's this category of
like all right we managed to get like
six relevant enough people to the story
to agree to an interview right from a
story that's already like well explained
and stuff and we'll make it a really
mediocre documentary about something
that you maybe heard about yeah and then
they spell it out and read dumb ways and
all the edits are really like how they
how they show social media and
documentaries and portray it is like
they can't just show a Facebook feed
they always have some dramatic kind of
angle of some fake Facebook feed and
it's always just looks terrible and and
the narrator's Annoying and it's always
just [ __ ] and this documentary about the
game's almost just awful I'd rather have
a 20 minute like video by uh
International yeah that's what I was
gonna say I was just like if I want a
documentary about the Game Stops buff
it's from internet story yeah they spent
like a 20-minute story into a two-hour
thing where they like just they like
smash cut and they do this with
everything it's like True Crime uh other
stuff there's a few really good
documentaries on Netflix I think like
I'm told it's really good uh What was
the uh racing Jeffrey Dahmer one was
that's like more yeah it's like a full
show that's a show oh okay they have the
don't [ __ ] with cats documentary for
Netflix though if you saw that yeah yeah
I didn't finish it actually I I thought
it was decent
I like I thought the story was amazing
like the actual story itself
very pretentious and like annoying yeah
people they got to tell the story were
just really off-putting yeah really
annoying because that's important right
who the the narrator who's telling the
story or the voices that we're getting
it through yeah I'd like to make or
break with the documentary and there's
ways you can use it well and there's
ways you can't like the what's the
documentary about that guy who's like a
he's um he's he's insane and he just
lies all the time and he pretends to be
he used to pretend to be like missing
kids in America oh I remember I remember
this documentary and so the whole
documentary is told from like his
perspective and he's telling you how
what's happening and what he did and how
it all goes and then like right at the
end they throw you this twist where like
they just kind of make you realize that
you've been listening to this whole guy
tell you the story and that you just
took his word for everything and that
this guy is is an impulsive liar yeah
and so like they throw this bone right
at the end it just makes you think like
oh I think half the [ __ ] he just said
was just complete [ __ ] but you have
no idea yeah and it's so good
it's so good because it's like it I like
documentaries that make you question the
people who are talking and that's why I
like it when there's multiple sides in
the documentary yeah yeah but more often
than not they only get one side and
stuff like that yeah basically what he
was pretending about was because there
was his family who had a who had a
missing child and that their child was
like missing for years and years and
then years later this guy uh pretended
to be their missing child right right
and he got away with it for like [ __ ]
years before people started like asking
questions yeah but when you're following
his perspective he starts throwing in
like little little questions to make you
question the family that took him in
yeah for me like them seemed like the
weird ones who were trying to hide
something yeah you may have seen like oh
maybe they murdered their kid and they
wanted to be like oh my God our kid
turned up and that we definitely didn't
kill our other kids yeah but the weird
thing is is that this kid that he was
pretending to be was from like Missouri
the guy pretending to be him was French
I know that I haven't seen the
documentary I know who you're talking
about though yeah he's like insane yeah
I know exactly who you're talking about
that and it's brilliant because it uses
this guy's like because he's really like
he's really well spoken he tells his
stories really well yeah and and it's I
love it when documentaries do this when
they like take the person and then like
by the way this guy might be full of
[ __ ] right and then they kind of use the
that's cool yeah it's really the guy's
story is pretty interesting even if it's
even if it's lies it's insane yeah like
it's so good that like it's worth the
watch yeah it's really good stuff I wish
put put the poster on screen you know
because it is it is a really good
documentary I highly recommend that
other one as well